[Música]
el presidente de ucrania volodymyr
selenski pidió a los países de occidente
una respuesta global firme contra los
crímenes de guerra de rusia haciendo
énfasis en el reciente ataque a 14 en
kiev el mandatario recibió el apoyo de
líderes europeos como el primer ministro
británico boris johnson quien realizó
una visita sorpresa al país
francia acude a las urnas este domingo
para la primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales más de 48 millones de
personas están llamadas a ser parte del
proceso electoral en américa a los
ciudadanos franceses tuvieron la
oportunidad de emitir su voto este
sábado
méxico se alista para decidir si el
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
continúa o no en el cargo la consulta
promovida por el mismo mandatario se
celebrará este domingo y es calificada
como una estrategia de propaganda del
jefe de estado
hola y bienvenidos a un nuevo
informativo en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz empezamos con las
últimas noticias relacionadas con la
guerra en ucrania el presidente
volodymyr selenski pidió una respuesta
global firme contra lo que calificó como
crímenes de guerra por parte de rusia
sus declaraciones hacen referencia al
reciente ataque en crema torch que dejó
52 civiles muertos varios países han
condenado la agresión y ha mostrado su
apoyo al mandatario se le es que recibió
en kiev al primer ministro británico
boris johnson quien le ofreció su ayuda
militar y financiera en el conflicto
un apretón de manos en kiev símbolo de
una amistad inquebrantable entre el
reino unido y ucrania boris johnson es
el primer líder del g7 en visitar quier
desde que comenzó la invasión rusa
descontados por el ejercito selenski y
johnson caminaron por las calles de la
ciudad una región que estuvo bajo el
fuego ruso hasta hace unos días
lluvia
y esta visita es una manifestación del
apoyo decisivo fuerte y constante de
reino unido a ucrania lo apreciamos y lo
recordamos siempre
desde el comienzo de la guerra londres
suministró valiosas armas antitanque al
ejército ucraniano y sobre los castigos
a rusia el primer ministro británico
también fue uno de los primeros en
sancionar a los oligarcas rusos en kiev
johnson prometió ayuda militar adicional
al ejército ucraniano incluyendo 120
vehículos blindados y nuevos sistemas de
misiles antibuque de weeds junto con
amigos y socios nosotros el reino unido
y otros viviendo les suministramos el
equipo de la tecnología los
conocimientos técnicos la inteligencia
para que ucrania no vuelva a ser
invadida
investiguen el considerado principal
aliado de ucrania ante europa prometió
una ayuda financiera adicional de 500
millones de dólares a través del banco
mundial también rindió homenaje al
ejército ucraniano la que consideró la
mayor hazaña armamentística del siglo 21
10 corredores humanitarios han sido
habilitados en ucrania para evacuar a
los residentes atrapados en las regiones
occidentales del país sin embargo el
gobernador de lugar que afirmó que se
necesitan más acciones
atrapados en sus propias ciudades desde
el inicio de la guerra
ahora estos ciudadanos pueden salir las
tropas de moscú se han reagrupado en el
este y el sur del país después de que
sus fuerzas se retiraran de las zonas al
norte de la capital kiev los residentes
de enol jódar melitópol tokmak bird
yanks y mariupol son llevados a la
ciudad central de sa por ella mientras
que los de otras cinco ciudades del
extremo oriental de la región de lugansk
serán evacuados avan mut fisio wing hoy
pueden ver con sus propios ojos el
estado actual de nuestras ciudades y de
nuestros pueblos conocer el aspecto en
que han quedado a causa de la invasión
rusa torné
hasta el momento los intentos de
establecer corredores humanitarios han
fracasado y las partes se culpan
mutuamente
moscú se había ofrecido a llevar a los
ciudadanos de rusia o belarús lo que
estaba fuera de discusión para quiera
ucrania acusa a rusia de impedir la
huida de los residentes atacando los
convoyes de civiles mientras que el
kremlin rechaza estas acusaciones
cambiamos de tema francia va a las urnas
este domingo para la primera vuelta de
las elecciones presidenciales más de 48
millones de personas están llamadas a
votar y los franceses residentes en
américa ya tuvieron la oportunidad de
emitir su voto en total son 12
candidatos los que se enfrentarán
durante esta jornada quién puede votar
todos son elegibles como candidato
electo qué pasa en una hipotética
segunda ronda les explicamos el sistema
electoral francés en el siguiente
informe
los votantes franceses eligen
directamente a su presidente por
sufragio universal el voto es abierto
para todos los ciudadanos franceses
mayores de 18 años siempre que no estén
legalmente inhabilitados para votar y
estén inscritos en la lista electoral
las mismas reglas se aplican a los
candidatos quienes también deben mostrar
un sentido de dignidad moral un término
vago sin una definición legal clara y
reunir 500 firmas de apoyo de
representantes electos
cualquiera que cumpla con estos
criterios es elegible para participar en
la primera ronda si nadie gana con una
mayoría absoluta más del 50 por ciento
de los votos los candidatos con mayor
puntuación se enfrentan en una segunda
vuelta aquí es donde entra a jugar el
voto estratégico en la segunda ronda
muchos votantes elegirán a un candidato
que inicialmente no apoyaron para
bloquear a otro contendiente esto
sucedió por primera vez en 2002 cuando
el ultraderechista jean-marie le pen
llegó inesperadamente a la segunda ronda
su oponente el titular de entonces
jacques chirac obtuvo más del 82% de los
votos el mayor margen en la historia del
país con 174 votos a favor el parlamento
paquistaní y destituyó al primer
ministro y ramtane lo que lo convierte
en el primer líder en la historia del
país es ser expulsado del cargo una
multitud de seguidores de la oposición
salió a las calles de islamabad para
celebrar lo que consideran como una
victoria tam había acusado a la
oposición de confabularse con eeuu para
destituirlo y le pidió a sus seguidores
que protesten en todo el país el domingo
174 miembros han registrado su voto a
favor de la resolución en consecuencia
la resolución para el voto de censura
contra el señor imran khan el primer
ministro de la república islámica de
pakistán ha sido aprobada por una
mayoría de la membresía total de la
asamblea nacional
méxico celebrada este domingo la
consulta de revocación de mandato del
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
el procedimiento fue impulsado por el
propio mandatario y ha dividido las
opiniones de los mexicanos
por primera vez de la historia los
mexicanos votarán sobre si su presidente
debe terminar su mandato anticipadamente
este inédito referéndum ha sido
promovido por el propio en 3 manuel
lópez obrador como respuesta a las voces
críticas a su gestión todo está listo
para que el próximo 10 de abril acudan a
votar todas las personas interesadas en
participar en este proceso las 92
millones 823 mil 216 ciudadanas y
ciudadanos inscritos en la lista nominal
de electores tendrán una papeleta
esperándoles en la casilla que les
corresponde los partidos de oposición
han llamado al boicot de la votación es
llegado a que lópez obrador busca
extender su mandato pese a que ha
expresado que no buscará la reelección
para el 2024 que el presidente va a
seguir
más los que queremos de esta reforma
esté bien para todos para mí es una
marcha en la que se refleja nuestra
nuestro descontento a lo que está
pasando es el ide es la manera que se
hizo lograr la ratificación que la
convirtieron una publicidad para a favor
del jugador genera por el mismo andrés
manuel lópez obrador mantiene un índice
de aprobación del casi el 60 por ciento
el presidente del órgano electoral
resaltó que se conocerán los resultados
de la misma noche del domingo lópez
obrador ha impulsado varias consultas
ciudadanos a lo largo de su mandato que
inició en el 2018 como la consulta sobre
la construcción del tren maya que contó
con menos del 1% de participación de los
electores de mexico también hubo uno
sobre la cancelación de un aeropuerto
casi terminado para la ciudad de mexico
fue una consulta de opinión no
vinculante y no regulado por la ley
federal el más reciente por el 2021
sobre la posibilidad de enjuiciar a ex
mandatarios por corrupción participaron
el 7 por ciento de los mexicanos
habilitados para votar pasamos a chile'
decenas de personas se reunieron en
santiago para rechazar la nueva
constitución que se está redactando en
el país los manifestantes que la nueva
carta magna que reemplazará a la que fue
promulgada en 1980 por la dictadura de
augusto pinochet pretende quitar
derechos como la propiedad privada
legalizar el aborto libre o expropiar
los fondos privados desde el pasado 4 de
julio la convención constitucional
trabaja en la redacción de la nueva
constitución producto de la presión
ejercida en 2019 hacia el gobierno del
entonces presidente sebastián piñera
durante el estallido social
seguidores y detractores del presidente
peruano pedro castillo se encontraron en
las calles de lima en el marco de una
ola de protestas contra el mandatario
que ha sacudido al país los
simpatizantes del presidente pedían el
cierre del congreso mientras que cientos
de manifestantes salieron nuevamente a
exigir la renuncia de castillo quien
enfrenta un juicio de destitución en las
últimas semanas las movilizaciones se
han agudizado debido al alza en los
precios del combustible y los alimentos
de esta manera despedimos este
informativo en france 24 gracias por
acompañarnos continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]